[Music]
eating at home the new normal now for
most of us around the world
kids don't go to school hence there are
no school meals
adults can't eat out because restaurants
and cafes are closed
that means back into the kitchen and do
your own cooking
a trend that shows an interesting side
effect organic and regional produce has
become even more popular
some just wanted to support local
farmers and vendors
but the main reason for a rise in
organic food seems to be
that most of us believe healthy food
will keep
us healthy too and during a pandemic
that's a pretty good incentive
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new and hopefully
tasty edition of our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and
i have to say all of that looked yummy i
don't know
where they did their grocery shopping
but if you're here in berlin you'll
probably
turn to organic food producers here in
the region
their business is thriving despite or
because
of the pandemic it's unusually quiet
in the farm shop here in breuervin
brandenburg
due to the pandemic only three customers
have been in this morning
the people from berlin aren't coming
it's very sad that people are forced to
stay home
the cafe is closed no weddings or events
allowed
the international green week that
happens in berlin every january was
online this year so
no catering contract the store and
catering service turnover is down by 75
per cent
it is a bit depressing also for
colleagues who can't do their normal
jobs
marzan and her husband didn't have to
put any of their employees on reduced
hours
they even hired 20 new people because
their organic produce delivery service
is booming they have 180 cows
and produce milk and cheese in the farm
dairy
the eco village bordovin also runs a
kitchen in the nearby town of ibas valde
which produces items such as chicken
stock pickled beet
and potato soup the organic farms
turnover
has risen 50 percent during the pandemic
to be honest i'm overwhelmed things here
have undergone dramatic changes
and dramatic changes are always a
challenge
at the moment he and his team are
delivering organic produce to some
3600 customers a week in brandenburg
berlin and also to supermarket chains
that's a third more than before covert
19.
germany has seen a 20 rise in sales of
organic goods during the pandemic
demand really spiked when people were a
bit panicked back in march
april but the other issue is trust
people need something they can trust in
this difficult time
the organic market exudes
trustworthiness so it's become
increasingly popular and smaller local
stores have also become more popular
many consumers are keen to support local
businesses
it's a positive development it's hard
work it's very challenging but it's
great
it's great the customers are supporting
us
on is already thinking ahead he wants to
build loyalty that will outlive the
pandemic
and for more i'm joined now by de bujoti
dar
he's the co-founder and director of
leucine rich
bio a microbiome company in the indian
city of bangalore
companies working on preventive health
care and precision medicine it's so very
good to have you with us dr dar
and i'm sure that you're familiar with
the saying you
are what you eat does this mean that to
all diseases perhaps
even including kobe 19 begin in the gut
well thank you thank you monica for
having me on the show
uh it's a pleasure um well yes uh
you know our intestine our gut as we as
we know it
uh you'll be amazed that to know that
around 70 percent of the immune system
reside in the intestine
and a lot of the diseases especially the
chronic diseases like
you know type 2 diabetes inflammatory
bowel disease
even mental uh diseases like you know
parkinson's and stuff like that
um have been shown to be linked to the
gut
i mean there is something called as gut
lung axis there is something called as
gut brain axis there is a gut
skin axis so yeah a lot of diseases
actually uh
uh you know have a link to the gut uh
and kovid19 since we are in a pandemic
uh you know
era so kovid19 what people have seen
in covid is that the sars cove two virus
that infects uh the lungs through a
receptor called ace2
now ace2 is also present in the
intestinal
intestine so a lot of the cells in the
intestine
have that particular receptor and hence
uh
the virus might also infect the
intestinal tissue
and not surprisingly a lot of
researchers have found
uh viruses in the stool samples of
people affected with this disease
exactly and and we also know uh because
not just the intestine but basically
throughout our body
uh we coexist with with millions of
microorganisms
uh partly also responsible for our
digestion of course
uh how can we support those um
to fight uh the enemy a virus for
example that
enters our body the microorganisms
especially in the gut since we are
talking about the gut microbiome
microbio microorganisms um they play a
very
crucial role in not only uh you know
metabolism of
lot of food that we eat but they also
synthesize lot of vitamins
uh in fact serotonin which is a
neurotransmitter is also
synthesized in the intestine so it's a
it's a very important
uh you know symbiotic relationship that
we have with our microorganisms
and the the best thing about the
microorganisms in the gut at least is
that they are malleable
uh what do i mean by malleable that
means they can be modulated
and they can be modulated by food and
hence we come to the very important
topic that that you have put across that
is how food can affect our health
so when we take care of the gut if we
take care of the gut by taking care of
the microorganisms that means the good
microorganisms should be
you know should be encouraged to grow so
that the bad microorganisms can't grow
then we will be healthy that's that's
the idea and how do we promote good
bacteria
or good microorganisms well there are
many ways
especially in the food uh the topic is
on this on the food
uh we can take you know give us give us
an example for example
i mean we all have to eat and that
includes you
give us the perfect meal especially now
in in the times of the pandemic
that that keeps us healthy and that
supports our immune system what's the
perfect meal
yeah so perfect meat uh meal to my mind
would have uh
you know equal representation of fiber
because fibers are very good prebiotics
they help
the probiotics grow and of course a lot
of vegetables
people have shown that you know taking
vegetables
really help our microorganisms cut down
on red meat
because uh again red meat uh leads to
something called as tmao and
that can cause a lot of issues have
whole cereals or
you know have a lot of nuts grains and
stuff like that
all of these in equal proportion
can also can help our gut stay healthy
does it matter whether it's organically
grown because people are really crazy
about organic produce right now
see organic foods are basically food
which are
uh grown without you know adding any
pesticides or stuff like that so they
are healthy in that way
uh but i mean if you if you eat food
or fruits vegetables which are grown
non-organically
but but have good proportion of you know
the legumes and the grains and the you
know
the nuts and omega-3 fatty acids that we
can have from
let's say you know fish and stuff like
that it should it should help
so yeah organic food is good but even if
you don't have organic food it is not
going to
change a lot of things so all right so
it's the right balance and nurturing
the good microorganisms in our body uh
dr deputy dar co-founder and director of
the microbiome company leucine rich bio
in bangalore thank you so much for your
time
thank you thank you monica for having me
time now for your questions over to
derek williams
what's the latest on whether humans can
pass the virus onto their pets
though we still don't know the exact
route it took through exactly which
species um the coronavirus came
from the animal world in the first place
so of course
there's been a lot of worry since the
beginning of the pandemic
that infected people might also infect
their pets proven examples of that
occurring
are are quite rare though though it does
happen and
and the affected animals are also
occasionally
mildly symptomatic one study
indicated that cats and ferrets
are more likely to get it than dogs in
evolutionary terms
ferrets are of course pretty closely
related to
to mink which seemed to be more
susceptible to the disease
in another horrendous chapter in this
pandemic
the detection of covet 19 at fur
farms in europe led to millions of mink
of being called last year the reason for
the drastic move
was the fear that populations of animals
at the farms
could serve as as reservoirs for soros
kofi 2
and also that packed cages of sick
mink might accelerate the development of
even more
dangerous new variants of the disease
to prevent that scenario in the future
researchers in both russia
and the us have been working on vaccines
that could be used in mink that that
aren't all that different
to some of the vaccines being developed
for us
if they're approved and licensed we
might even see the first
mink being vaccinated in a month or two
and and manufacturers say
they could quickly adapt their products
for for other domesticated animals
including
dogs and cats so i'm guessing pets
probably won't be far behind
[Music]
as we're all waiting to get vaccinated
why not go for a sugary substitute in
the meantime
this syringe shaped cake may not protect
you from kobe 19
but it'll certainly sweeten your day a
bakery in germany came up with the idea
and it's not their first pandemic
inspired product
remember the hunt for toilet rolls last
year don't think about it
just dig in